here's what we were going to start with
here's okay and talking - he wasn't
talking to reporters yesterday talking
to 105 seven the fan in Baltimore
Jason Laughlin for about Taysom Hill
here's what Payton had to say about his
future franchise quarterback for those
that aren't sold it's it's probably
because they haven't seen enough of him
in games and I can certainly understand
that now that being said we've seen
hundreds of reps that weren't
necessarily regular-season games and
we've seen some of the things that we
feel like he can do on a consistent
basis but I think look I think that's
often the case with any new player and
so we're new meaning if that time comes
we're tastings transitioning into
quarterback only people are excited or
anxious to see hey how does he function
down in down out at that position we
think that he's gonna be an outstanding
NFL quarterback big cat it's amazing to
me how many people are dismissive of
Taysom Hill as a quarterback simply
because he's thrown between 10 and 15
passes and regular season games Sean
Payton has proven his genius time and
again over the past 15 years as a head
coach and before that as an offensive
coordinator if Peyton believes in the
guy I believe in the guy and like Peyton
said they have access to him in practice
go back and watch the preseason games on
NFL game pass they're there you can see
how he'll performs when he's the guy
who's out there on the field this isn't
a fluke and he was in that wild-card
game against the Vikings he was the best
player on the field for either team and
if they just used him a little bit more
they would have advanced to the next
round
so preseason games again still get a
sense but you still but you still was
that Patrick mahomes played in preseason
games as a second-stringer also before
he became the starter I mean we didn't
know Patrick mahomes was Patrick mahomes
until he was the starter on a regular
basis nobody was clamoring for Patrick
mahomes to be the next great thing after
he started week 17 of the 2017 season it
wasn't until he came out and set the NFL
on fire in 2018 but the Chiefs knew Andy
Reed knew and Sean Payton as it relates
to Taysom Hill
he knows don't point at me don't put
your finger in my face because guess
what you just admitted it right there
you just said yourself no
when times go Patrick go home so he
started playing meaningful downs no one
should be talking about Taysom Hill
until he starts playing meaningful downs
Mike when Taysom Hill goes on the field
the defense thinks that it's a trick
play they think something's afoot they
know that the completely different
defensive scheme mindset then if you
have Taysom Hill on the field for 70 60
70 snaps a game that is a different
beast altogether I'm not saying that he
can't get there I'm saying I'm not gonna
call him that because he has six or
seven awesome trick plays that they ran
in a playoff game but they lost well but
I think what he's done over the years is
more than that and his skill set is
uncanny he's at times the fastest guy on
the field even when the fastest
receivers are out there he is physically
dominant the question is what kind of
offense can Sean Payton devise for him
and when we see what the Ravens have
done with Lamar Jackson and what they've
put around him in Baltimore I think Sean
Payton kind of looks forward to the
opportunity to show that he can do the
same thing I'm just telling you if a hey
you can either accept what Payton says
or you can ignore it or you can say he's
lying he's puffing whatever the case may
be I don't I don't
I'm not saying Sean Payton jumping could
be right but I just don't care about a
guy who's who was great in practice was
great in a few situations and great in
pre-season I want to see it week in week
out for 50 60 snaps running the ball if
we say it about Lamar Jackson you know
the Pitt the hits piling up we got to
say it about taste in mail if he's gonna
run the ball a bunch we'll two hits pile
up and guess what he also is Mike he's
gonna be 30 years old before this
started this NFL season okay
so you're gonna tell me he's gonna be
the fastest guy on the field for the
next five years when he which he has to
be good for three or four or five years
to be a franchise quarterback to be in
that category so you're gonna tell me
that he's gonna keep having that speed
that beats everyone when he's 35 years
old I don't believe it
well first of all we are seeing players
extend their high level abilities deeper
into their life span
training because of nutrition also also
look and working with Sean Payton and a
lot of this depends on how long Payton
remains the coach of the New Orleans
Saints but he signed an extension this
past year there had been this vague
sense he was going to go somewhere else
and try to become the first coach to
ever win a Super Bowl with two different
teams but if Payton is there for the
long haul and we see the transition of
Taysom Hill from this guy who can do
everything from this guy who is one of
the fastest players on the field into a
quarterback who makes the kinds of
decisions the Drew Brees makes the plays
are set up for Drew Brees to have an
open receiver this is something Chris
sim says time and again what happens in
that offense isn't as much on the
quarterback shoulders as you would think
it's the structure of the play it's the
design of the play it's Sean Payton's
genius that allows the quarterback to
have that open receiver and make that
play work if Taysom Hill transitions
into that then it doesn't matter if he
can't run he won't need to Mike if
Taysom Hill is a franchise quarterback
quarterback a truly a franchise
quarterback like you're saying why do
the Saints keep signing backup
quarterbacks because and I thought we've
talked about this before but I'm happy
to revisit it well but I think this is a
truthful answer they need a backup
quarterback who can run the offense that
is in place with drew worries because
what does taste a mill doing during
practice you're saying that they're
installing a completely different
offense in all these practice reps that
Sean Payton is saying he's fantastic at
their running they're completely
different offense now it doesn't add up
I usually problem mated you I think you
have you case here's what you always
overlook here's what you always overlook
when you make this point you overlook
the impact of ripping up the playbook
and adopting another one on the other 10
players on the field it's not just
saying well we have a different
quarterback we're going to run a
different offense we're gonna run the
Taysom Hill plays not the Drew Brees
plays you then have to get your
offensive line to block a different way
to think of things a different way
because of the possibility that Taysom
Hill may run around and then finally
throw the ball so you can't stray
downfield you've got Michael Thomas who
has to play a different way knowing it's
Taysom Hill
not drew brees with a slightly different
offense or a very different offense with
taste mil so I think it's the whole
package I really do think that's why
they keep finding a a game-day
backup for Drew Brees and they continue
to have Taysom Hill in that separate
role once Brees is gone they're gonna
cave already made it clear they gave you
got 21 million for two years they've
already made it clear that he's the guy
next year if Brees doesn't come back
Mike Mike Mike what are you doing what
how do you how do you explain Sean
Peyton saying that you do not see him in
practice running at the office is he
running at a Sam Hill offense in
practice or a Drew Brees offense in
practice tell me that I don't know maybe
he's running the scout team offense I
don't know you can't throw out the place
for the other ten guys their practice
won't put how to play football you don't
think he's running the same offense in
practice wait a minute are you saying
that he's practicing with the starting
offense it's a different issue together
you got fifty three guys on the team you
got a lot going on at practice it
doesn't mean that Taysom Hill is out
there at practice running the number one
offense with the number one offense that
makes no sense that's what drew Brees
does tasty meals either gonna run the
scout team or he's gonna run the backup
offense part of what you're saying
Taysom Hill being a franchise
quarterback you two two out of the three
things that you point you are his reps
in pre-season and his reps in practice
what are those reps are those the Drew
Brees offense or are those team
elephants are they throwing it out and
running two totally different offenses
for pre-season and practice it went went
a some hills on the field because that's
just the part that doesn't add up to me
I don't understand if taste the middle
is truly a franchise quarterback if
taste the male is truly a franchise
quarterback he's probably better than
Drew Brees right now why would you say
that because he's younger faster more
dynamic like everything that is talked
about with taste mill how he is such a
great quarterback if you truly believe
all these things he probably would be
your best option
maybe at one and definitely at two
I just sent a text message to someone
who would know the answer to the
question on which offense Taysom Hill
runs when he's practicing we'll see in
this segment go ahead and think that you
made incredible points again I try to be
a good host because you're on my Friday
guests but I still believe that the
truth is hiding in plain sight Sean
Payton believes in Taysom Hill as a
potential franchise quarterback I'm not
saying he's a franchise quarterback
right now but at some point he is going
to move on from Drew Brees and he's
going to build the offense around taste
him he'll remember a few weeks ago when
Payton blurted out that this is Drew
Brees last year and Brees was like I
said in my last year necessarily and
Payton had to put the toothpaste back in
the tube I think he's anxious to see
what he can do
would Taysom Hill before Taysom Hill
strays too far beyond his 30th birthday
so look here's what will happen here's
what'll happen if Jason though becomes a
franchise quarterback
you'll never mention it if he doesn't
I'll never hear the end of it okay so
what is a defined franchise quarterback
because Mike the other you know when you
see it you know guys see it you know a
franchise quarterback when you see it
alright so I haven't seen it there we go
so I'm right I said potential of course
he's not one now what's wrong with you
that's why we're talking about it we're
talking about what he's good be not what
he is now what he could be is there a
world where you can understand that Sean
Payton wants to keep tasting he'll happy
and he said to him you're my guy I want
to keep you happy I want to keep you you
know locked in ready to go for these for
this wrinkle we have in the offense so
he is promising him behind closed doors
that you will be the heir apparent and
guess what comes with that going out
publicly every few months in saying I
love tasty meal he's incredible but big
cat he was due to make four million this
year they tore that up and they're
paying him 21 million over two years
with 16 million guaranteed if this is a
ruse by Sean Payton he is financially
committed to that ruse you're paying the
guy 21 million for two years look at
what other players on the team are
making and this is a gadget player this
is a fluke player that is getting that
kind of money obviously they have bigger
plans for him next year and they may
have bigger plans for him
this year we may see more of him this
year we already see him when it's time
to throw a deep ball because Drew Brees
can't any longer and it's the plain
truth we're gonna see I think we're
gonna see more Taysom Hill this year
that's a totally separate issue and I
agree with what you just said because I
do think Taysom Hill adds a wrinkle and
element to this offense that is
fantastic and him as a player when he
has to only get in the field and take
you know six seven snaps a game is
incredible and what that what that adds
to a defense of preparation makes it
very very difficult to guard the Saints
that's a totally different option you
don't think that Sean Payton who loves
offensive football and wants to score
points and wants to give the defense as
many tough looks to deal with wouldn't
financially invest in adding a
completely new wrinkle to his offense
would taste some he'll that makes it so
so hard to guard on someday he's worth
it at what he obviously is worth it at
what he adds in terms of the element of
brady Taysom Hill into the feet onto the
field
for seven or eight plays a game and
having everything change that's a lot of
scratch for seven or eight plays a game
over the course of this year is how many
plays per game we'll see him next year
do you think he'll be the starting
quarterback next year yes or no he he'd
better be well you're talking way to
evade the question senator yes or no
well do you think he'll be the starting
quarterback next year I don't think
it'll be a good start at quarterback yes
or no do you think we'll be the starter
[Music]
8:15 8:15 a.m. Eastern May 15 20 20 big
cats says the Taysom Hill will not be
the starting quarterback for the New
Orleans Saints next
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports